[Music]
sean mendes is opening up to fans about
his mental health after announcing he's
postponing his north american wonder
world tour dates for three weeks sharing
his decision on instagram he writes i've
been touring since i was 15 and to be
honest it's always been difficult to be
on the road away from friends and family
after a few years off the road i felt
like i was ready to dive back in but
that decision was premature and
unfortunately the toll of the road and
the pressure has caught up to me and
i've hit a breaking point sean added
that after speaking with health
professionals and his team he needs time
to quote heal take care of myself and my
mental health
john previously opened up to us about
the feelings of loneliness he sometimes
faces while on tour there's always this
like two and a half week point when
you're like why am i so like lonely and
depressed after two and a half weeks i
gotta get back home and see my family
you're not you're just like in that mode
like oh yeah we're out here for a minute
but he did ensure us that touring is one
of his favorite parts of the job if i
had to choose one thing in my career to
do or it's touring i always like to
think about touring as like
you can make a show this big ball of
happiness right and then you just like
travel the world and if you're lucky
maybe that concert can be five of the 15
000 people in the arena's best night
sure so if you're traveling around the
world and you're making all of these
people's best night of the year it's
this incredibly positive thing and shawn
recently announced his new social impact
initiative attached to his 87 date
wonder world tour in partnership with
disney plus the sean mendes foundation
plans to give wunder grants to youth
changemakers working in the areas of
children's health and wellness in every
tour market sean will also visit
children's hospitals in the us to grant
wishes to patients
[Music]
john's announcement comes after justin
bieber had to postpone the remainder of
his north american tour as he deals with
his recent ramsey hunt syndrome
diagnosis which causes facial paralysis